how you know'm people on dave rubin this
is the reuben report and we are doing
the biggest gayest show we've done we do
a lot of gay stuff here it's been a big
gay year usually good news I have
brought two of YouTube's gayest gay
superstars Hank Chen Davey wavey thank
you guys the gayest one you guys where I
look through the list of gay YouTube
people and both of you were on the top
of the list there and here we are you
ready to be gay and do some more we're
on YouTube right now so this is this
should be very cool hi this is so
exciting there you go all right let's
talk some gay stuff we actually got some
great gay news this morning
Derrick Gordon who is a Division one
basketball player at UMass came out he
is the first Division one basketball
player to come out this of course comes
on the heels of Jason Collins in the NBA
Michael Sam n-c-double-a football player
who will make it to the NFL in a couple
months now you guys are big jocks right
now - big jocks here to talk sports I've
been working out can we agree that
whether you're an athlete or a sports
man or not can we agree that having
another out athlete is all good this is
just good news right I love it I think
any kind of visibility no matter who it
is is fantastic I think the power of
coming out is through the individual and
not through like policies and government
and thingies and laws and stuff like
that it has to be that personal
connection so I'm sure he's got that
ripple effect of his immediate circle
and that's going you know the people do
not have to process that and decide
whether to accept him for who he is or
cut it off yeah hopefully it's the form
all good all good well I mean it's it's
it's breaking stereotypes it's like this
is a guy who's not a hairdresser which
is what we see with gay people on TV
he's he's something different I mean the
question that we had was is he any good
yeah so he's pretty decent that's what I
that's what I suppose the dribbling
level with this ball with the orange
ball yeah in the to the kick a hoop in
the net that one's fun yeah so okay so
if it's all good when do we get to stop
celebrating this stuff because I think
at some point we do have to get past
like everybody that comes out we have to
like
it literally is the number one trending
thing on Twitter as of our taping this
so like where are we are we close to
that point where we can just be like oh
you came out great we're just now right
I don't want her though well this makes
me think I shouldn't have come out I
should have like held it a secret for
years and then like had this big thing
because you get so much publicity from
it like none of us would ever be talking
about this guy you want to be trending
on Twitter but now he is and and it's
great that he came out but this is like
millions and millions of dollars of
publicity yeah I think that's an
interesting point so for three public
people that are out is is there a little
bit of resentment or something obviously
we're not n-c-double-a but is there a
little bit of like oh I could have held
it in until something big happen and
then it would have been even bigger or
something like that I could not have
held it in anyone who went to middle
school knows that I could not have held
it in yeah but also I don't think I
would be here sitting at this desk with
you had I not come out YouTube was my
public outing and to answer an earlier
question I feel like we should never
stop celebrating I mean are we really
gonna add a certain point cancel the gay
pride parade because it's no longer
relevant every year that every year that
its Pride Month people do talk about
that no because every time a black
person wins an Oscar I feel like that's
also noteworthy and that in the Civil
Rights you know for for other groups has
has continued yeah in spite of its
longer history than the gay rights
movement it's great do you guys think
that the the sports thing is more about
the beer from the media or actually what
goes on in the locker room because
that's what everyone thinks that somehow
if there's a gay person in the locker
room even though there obviously have
been gay people in the locker room
forever long time for a long time but
somehow that's gonna the players are
gonna freak out but I to me it's more
about the media how the media is gonna
react then actual players I really think
they're gonna people probably just don't
care like it's 2014 and the players are
probably like you liked it that's great
let's go play the game yeah but it's
kind of I think the it's like the net
it's become the talking point this year
it's like that next barrier the next
thing to break through yeah when do you
think last question on this when do you
think we will have an openly straight
WNBA player I say ten years did you get
the joke there you got the joke I did
IIIi hopefully soon a lot of lesbians in
that we support we support you there's
always what I want to say I think that's
a perfect finish we openly support
straight women in the WNBA okay let's
move on so you guys probably heard about
this whole mozilla firefox' CEO fallout
situation brendan eich is the CEO or was
the CEO of Mozilla until last week he
donated $1,000 to prop 8 in 2008 the bad
side of prop 8 and then OkCupid found
out about this and they blocked their
site OkCupid on the Mozilla Firefox
browser hello there Mozilla Firefox user
part of this interruption of your
OkCupid experience Mozilla's new CEO
Brendan Eich is an opponent of equal
rights for gay couples we would
therefore prefer that our users not use
Mozilla software to access OkCupid ok so
then of course this blown up into a blew
up into a giant firestorm he stepped
down but now it turns out that there
might be a little hypocrisy here because
the CEO of OkCupid has donated money to
to some things that perhaps he's not so
proud of now ok cupid's founder and CEO
Sam jaegeun made a $500 donation to a
congressional candidate who opposed
same-sex marriage voted against the ban
on sexual orientation based job
discrimination and for prohibition of
gay adoptions records show that jaegeun
who's also the CEO of match.com donated
500 dollars to representative Chris can
and who's Republican in Utah in 2004 so
before we get to the hypocrisy for this
guy were you guys happy to see the CEO
of Mozilla go now this is $1,000 that he
did roughly five years ago I think a
thousand dollars I think it's a
significant amount of money and I think
you know when people always say put your
money where your mouth is people vote
with their dollars so and also it's not
just that money it's also his lack of
like retracting or even or the
statements supporting that donation even
years later right so we have no
indication that he doesn't still feel
that way but a lot has
in five years and it is possible that
change and it was only $1000 so was this
a bit of an overreaction to sort of he
didn't get fired he stepped down yeah I
think he had the opportunity to say you
know what like it was 2008 things are
different now I have evolved my thoughts
on gay marriage and and you know what I
shouldn't have done that he had some
opportunity to kind of apologize yeah
and he really just kind of stood with it
and said so even if his thoughts haven't
evolved
should he did he have the right no but
should someone be have the right to be
the CEO of a pretty public company and
not be for gay marriage I think it's an
interesting question I guess maybe the
answer is probably yes but I don't think
it's I don't think it's smart business
sense like I don't think it was yeah
totally I mean you know if I didn't like
you know green people I wouldn't say it
because likely some of my customers are
green yeah I mean like it just it just
shut your mouth yeah it was just like
such a distraction but he kind of had to
if they were gonna move forward at all
and in your he kind of had to sit down
what do you guys think about the the
hypocrisy of the OkCupid guy so he bans
the Mozilla you know Explorer or
whatever for his site but it turns out
that he has donated to some things that
he may not be so proud of too but I
think the difference being that since
this is like years and years later he
has had the opportunity to say you know
I supported this then I don't support it
now and so I think people can kind of
make that differentiation yeah
are either one of you guys fans of Urban
Outfitters by any chance
I like Urban Outfitters yeah I think
that t-shirt might be it's not I trust
you I know you gladly will take it off
have a look yeah because the owner the
president and founder of Urban
Outfitters has donated money to Rick
Santorum's campaign he said some other
anti-gay stuff so it is weird how we
sort of pick and choose who we decide to
rail against what we hear that on
youtube all the time if we wear
something that is from Urban Outfitters
and people recognize that people will
email me and be like you wore that shirt
it's from Urban Outfitters I can't
believe you're supporting this so what's
your personal policy on that so you do
where urban outfitters despite knowing
that I mean I full disclosure I have
plenty of Urban Outfitters than I do
yeah I mean I didn't realize when I
bought the shirt that I was you know
look I'm the Internet you can't win no
matter what you do and and you can try
to tread as you could you could donate a
million dollars to schools in Africa and
people will email you and say you know
what there's a lot of work that needs to
be at home all right so with every so
since we're winning the war here right
since we're winning this game war it's I
mean we're getting gay marriage in every
state every couple weeks some activist
judge does something and we get some
more gay marriage do you think in a
weird way that the gay community should
somehow figure out a way to be a little
more gracious somehow for these people
should we figure it not gracious exactly
but should we figure out a way to be a
little more open to these people that
maybe did things five years ago that
whether they're proud of it or not I
know it's putting I know it's putting it
on us which i think is sort of difficult
because we still don't have full
equality but I think there's something
to that that there's these people
holding on to something that they're
losing and maybe we should somehow
figure out a way to embrace them a
little bit more instead of everyone just
fighting all the time
I gave you a lot to work with yeah I
think the question that people are
trying to ask is even if you felt this
way have your thought processes evolve
do you feel this way now and that's
giving people that's giving people who
are in positions of power and influence
in the public eye the opportunity to say
either yes or no and you know we've all
grow and learn I'm not the same person
that I was five years ago and and so
people are wanting to see where their
leaders stand today and so I think the
leaders who are not being as tactful as
they should be are getting a little bit
of blowback
yeah I am I don't care so much what
someone said ten years ago and then the
whole thing with the gay rights movement
is that we're hoping to change hearts
and minds and when we do that with
someone we can't hold that against them
that that their opinion is now different
and and I think that's a great thing if
they still think that I shouldn't get
married I won't I will not have
compassion no problem yeah all right
well said okay let's talk about the gay
mafia because that's been the big story
this week because Bill Maher on overtime
which is the online only show that they
do on real time after the show he
implied that there actually is a gay
mafia let's take a look what do you
think of the Mozilla CEO having to step
down over
donation to pro proposition 8 group yeah
the Mozilla which I'm wearing right now
by the way I didn't know what Mozilla
was I saw it on my computer but it's
it's Firefox right it's the browser open
empty so this guy apparently does not
want gay people to get married and he
had to step down what do you think of
that the question is because he gave
$1000 eight years ago and it's come back
to haunt him when he gave it when
President Obama is still was against gay
marriage so I don't think it's very fair
good point
also I think there is a gay mafia I
think if you cross them you do get why I
really do okay I think there was some
odd sexual connotations for the way he
said whacked wasn't there something
there there's something something seemed
a little bizarre okay so they talked a
little bit about the Mozilla CEO as we
just did in the previous segment but he
the way bill says it he's half joking
but the way he's sort of leaning in his
chair is also like yeah I'm in this
thing I'm in Hollywood I'm pretty
entrenched and I know this thing exists
so you too professional gay people does
the gay mafia exist Davey wavey no
comment how much you're gonna pay you
don't think there's an organized group
of gay people that are meeting somewhere
that are powerful Holly it's not that
organized I think there's a group of gay
I think they're gay friends circles as
there are on any professional setting
and they do favors for each other I
don't believe that anyone is pulling
strings Yeah right so when the right
wing people because we've got a list of
things that people claim that the gay
mafia does they say that you know they
started the firestorm the duck dynasty
thing that was the gay mafia but then
the gay mafia lost that one I guess cuz
duck dynasty still on Alec Baldwin
everybody's favorite hate monger he lost
his gig at MSNBC that must be the gay
mafia and then the CEO obviously of
Mozilla so you guys really don't you
just don't believe it well I think what
there is is probably a group of very
wealthy gay men that get together and
decide like what Kent what candidates
they're gonna fund where they're gonna
put them on
the things that they're gonna try to
influence with their dollars I don't
think that they're like thinking that
they're gonna make some firestorm about
duck dynasty I think that was a media
yeah and and I think the with the
Firefox like it's it's public opinion
that that the sky was like gay mafia now
is public opinion that's why he stepped
down so I that I agree with that what
they're calling gay mafia really is just
glad HRC the rest of that stuff which
whether you like those organizations or
not every group in this country has
their advocacy groups that are trying to
to do things would it be the worst thing
in the world if we actually had a gay
mafia
if they really if it came out but yes
there is a group of gay people trying to
pull some strings so they gay people
become more equal and you see better
images of gay people immediate things
like that would that be that bad if it's
phrase like that the answer is no but I
think the gay mafia are all the
fourteen-year-old white girls on Twitter
back up there people like you did too
and it will come to your defense for
everything every host shirtless video
it's all the fourteen-year-old girls
that click like 60 year old man yeah a
YouTube video at playlist live and I had
to kiss straight guys in it and I was
like no one is gonna kiss me
look no straight guy is gonna do this I
had like 60 fourteen-year-old girls
running with me up to these guys like
alright well there you have it I have
brought on to professional gay youtubers
I know a little something about this
myself and we don't know if there is a
gay mafia which maybe means we're on
we're on the outs probably Oh God invite
us in guys if this is really around
hello really okay a court in Egypt this
week sentenced four men up to eight
years in prison for yeah homosexuality
prosecutors had accused the men of
holding quote deviant parties and
they're using a law that bans debauchery
- to put these guys in jail and put them
on trial the Middle East seems to be
pretty backwards as we've talked often
about related to anything with human
rights women's rights gay rights etc etc
we've got a math that
gives you a little more about gay rights
around the globe and basically red and
the darker red you are the worse it is
blue and the darker blue you are the
better it is and and grey it's pretty
it's pretty decent how do we get the
middle east into the 21st century
I get it we're not perfect here we do
not have full marriage equality here we
got plenty of problems here but how do
we get that section of the world to at
least come a little bit further in this
direction well funny you should say the
word come in that question because if
they look at their own history Egypt
gave you Cleopatra who was one of the
more sexually deviant characters in
history apparently this woman used to
have hundreds of men contribute to her
baths good for her skin or whatever and
I was like and now we have an issue with
one-on-one I was like I don't know I
don't understand the logic what hundreds
of men did what to contribute to her
baths contribute come in a bathtub and
she would bathe in it I've never heard
that are you kidding me it's all over
the Internet
I've never so she was yeah she was base
now I did not know that true it's it's
one of [ __ ] [ __ ] with sexually deviant
whether or not that's like a
mythological whatever you know what I
mean if you kind of like in every I love
it all these conservative cultures even
like Asian in me outlets you know I'll
just pointing her to myself Chinese
history there's some weird-ass [ __ ] that
went down and then they're like oh no
gay people no gay people I'm like really
because y'all did some kinky ass [ __ ]
back in your dynasties yeah yeah do we
have any right get them to look at their
own history and realize the hypocrisy
and you know like where did we come from
where we going well I guess that in the
case of Egypt so that's a place where
science and liberalism were rewarded a
little more a long time ago and they've
sort of gone backwards do we have any
right in the United States to tell these
people how to live well I know all the
YouTube commenters are gonna say no
because every time I posed that question
everyone yells and says you you know
right we need to mind our own business
it's a different culture
what should we care about the their
human rights well I think we should my
my we are human beings and we are tied
by that thread by eighth most viewed
country is Saudi Arabia which is
interesting right on that map in color
red you know in it's amazing I think
what's being done on YouTube not that
we're saving the world or curing cancer
or you know but I think it is a step in
that journey towards getting people to
move a little bit forward with the way
that they view gay rights do you get a
lot of comments from from people from
Saudi Arabia in that part of the world
because we did a video last week about
women driving in Saudi Arabia and I
actually got a lot of men from Saudi
Arabia angry saying that women shouldn't
be allowed to drive and if you let women
drive there's gonna be more car
accidents all this stuff and I kind of
felt bad for them more than anything
else because they're just being
indoctrinated with this stuff
so it's like I can't hate them really
because that's what they're being taught
but do you get a lot of comments on your
videos I get a lot of emails from people
that are in countries where it's like
not as accepted but the important thing
is like you're starting a dialogue like
you're starting a conversation that they
might not otherwise have yeah and like
is it going to solve all the problems no
but maybe it's gonna get that ball
moving a little bit yeah is there
anything that the government should do I
mean should we be Egypt is our ally we
give them a lot of money should that be
contingent on human rights I think I
think we should tread carefully cuz I
don't understand what's going on when it
comes to business affairs I don't run
this country I'm not a policy maker
because I know that there's a lot of
attention I thought it said policymaking
here isn't to me Dave and make it listen
to me oh but you know I mean there's a
lot that goes on we don't know kind of
wila wheelin and dealin goes on between
these world leaders and I think in order
to protect American interests we have to
tread carefully when we stick our nose
into other people's business but with
that being said human to human I think
that's why we do what we do because I
like reaching people on a personal level
I to get a lot of people in these very
conservative countries including the
Middle East as well as parts of Asia who
in their closeted and
and I do what I can from that level but
I and that's that's the only thing I'm
able to do at this point
yeah well I guess everyone does they're
a little part by the way we should note
that gay cities which is a big gay
website they did their poll of what the
best gay city is in the world and last
year it was Tel Aviv Israel which is
smack in the middle of the Middle East
what is with those crazy Jews that
they're down with the gays while
everybody else around them seems to want
to kill him Barbara Walters after
50-plus years doing network television
she has announced her retirement and
earlier this week on the view she
actually gave us a date let's take a
look you may remember that last spring I
said that I would leave daily television
in a year so here we are it's almost one
year later and I have decided that
Friday May 16th will be my final
appearance on the view as a co-host will
be a two-hour ABC News primetime special
looking back at my career for over 50
continuous years on the air man I've
been doing a youtube show for a year and
I think that's a long time 50
consecutive years on air so I want to
talk about Barbara first and then we'll
talk about the view why is it that
Barbara Walters doesn't get into that
gay icon status that these older women
seem to get into of course for me the
Golden Girls but all there's just plenty
of older women you know Judy Garland
whoever that the gay community loves for
some reason Barbara Walters even though
she's a proponent of gay rights and is
on TV every day and talking about
liberal causes things like that she
never made it there for some reason
I just I find it hard to trust anyone
with eyes that are just that big a
problem with a woman with work no no
yeah you know I I think that she comes
across as like a little pretentious at
the same time I appreciate the barriers
that she has broken down and that she
was like really at the forefront of what
she was doing but I just don't feel like
the same warm fuzzy I don't know she
kind of strikes me as a [ __ ]
Wow all right to that point is is it
partly because she's a newswoman so
she's more serious than gays like
over-the-top right days like camp she
doesn't have a drag doppelganger I think
is the thing it's hard to you're right
it's hard to impersonate her and you
know all of our icons are performers
mostly yeah they're easier to emulate
and Betty White is a comedian even
though she's not a singer yeah but
shouldn't we love someone like Barbara
Walters who did break down all those
barriers and is actually doing something
I mean she did she did for women what we
want someone to do for gay people right
I think we do love her I love her I
highly respect her I think she's fierce
as how I wished she liked rains in the
view and like cuts Oh co-hosts down as
they step out a lot brings a man and I
think people really respect her I
certainly really adore her and I think
she's find her to be inspirational and
very ambitious but I think you I never
thought about this but yeah she's
difficult to like iconic eyes whatever
whatever that word is right so let's
talk about the view a little bit cuz I
think there's something really
fascinating with the view and gay people
I there was a couple years where I watch
the view every day when Rosie was on and
joy was on they were so amazing together
there Rosie obviously is gay joy is as
close to gay as possible I guess without
being gay what is it about the view and
what is it about a group of women that
are outspoken that gays love because if
there was a show of five gay guys
sitting around a table or four gay guys
gays would not be into we would never
want so so what is that what is that
well I I like to watch it because I like
to see how like disinterested joy is and
she's just like trying to get through
the show that she's just like is this
really another week of the view it's
probably why she left the view after
what tour she was on for twelve years or
something like yeah yeah it's yeah I
think you can't paint all gay people
with a broad brush that like all gay
people like the view but it's the same
reason that people like the view it's
it's a distraction from everyday life
like there's a lot of drama there's a
lot of cattiness that goes on yeah and
and you know people people like that
it's what is it reading yeah it's like
kind of legal it's like meaningless okay
yeah
okay right what does it feel about what
is it though about gay guys that are you
guys with me that if it had been a table
of four gay guys that it never would
have done nearly as well as having women
maybe middle-aged women would have liked
it
I was middle-aged women love gay guys
but that gay guys wouldn't have been as
into it if it had been gay guys at the
table I agree I think it's I think
there's not as wide of appeal if it's
all just gay men but that's a cultural
thing for another that's another side
conversation but I'm talking about for
gay men watching it why is it that gay
men would be more inclined to watch a
group of women at a table than gay men
at a table I think it's the same reason
why gay men who loved sex in the city
because that show those were gay men
masquerading as women I think the the
cast of the view those are gay men
masquerading as women I think those
conversations remind us of private
conversations that we have I think we
love the fashion we love the hair we
there's there's a certain element of
glam and and it's elevated it's it's
heightened it's our lives heightened for
you know and now you're right we can't
paint it with the big brush but their
appeal is the same reason that the
reality shows have appeal yeah and
fashion shows have appeal so so there
you go yeah
all right final thought on this I was
thinking you know Barbara said the thing
about the the 50 years and all that do
you think that's just like a thing
that's long gone people that are gonna
have these sort of iconoclastic I think
is the word before careers where they
last fifty years in the business is she
really one of the sort of I don't want
to call her a dinosaur but you know it I
mean is she is that it really that we
won't have people that last this long in
this kind of business well I mean it I
don't think so I think there's going to
be other people that that are doing that
but the important thing with Barbara
Walters is that like she broke down so
many barriers that stood in her way that
like like in that sense she's legendary
and what she did right and there will be
other people at the front of their game
doing things that have never been done
but those were some like really big
walls to break down yeah so I guess
there aren't that many walls to break
down hopefully right I think different
walls are just to pop up not right for
her right now
or not for people of her you know not
for white women in broadcasting right
there'll be other walls to break down
well speaking of walls to break down
there's a good chance we're gonna have a
female president in 2016 have you heard
of this Hillary Clinton woman apparently
she's gonna run for president that's
what everyone's saying and as we are
doing our big gay spectacular show this
week I want to talk about why gays love
Hillary we were just talking about why
gays sorta don't love Barbara Walters
but gays love freakin Hillary Clinton
every gay loves her they just did a huge
fundraiser for her at the Abbey here in
West Hollywood
tons of gays were there she's getting
all the money gays gays voted far more
for her in 2008 than they did for Barack
Obama what is it about Hillary and the
game well you know I think it's it's a
mutual appreciation because my first gay
pride parade was 2005 New York City in
in the world of gay rights like that was
a lifetime ago that was a very different
world than where we're at now yeah and
she was marching in that parade yeah and
I was senator from New York yeah and I
was like so impressed like there she was
with her rainbow flag and so I think
part of the reason why we love her is
because she supports us so and not every
gay likes her by the way can I
personally in good conscience can't vote
for another Clinton or Bush I just
simply will not do it interesting we
left England for a reason and I don't
think that families I never had anyone
in my family that was president have you
guys not yeah yes I'm pretty sure they
don't need more of them you know what I
mean because then we're just gonna have
Melia 2026 I just think it's so I just
can't know I know an Obama really
sickening the worst shipping of these
people do you think she's gonna suffer
in a weird way from every Democrat in
2016 is gonna be for gay rights right I
mean it's it's in the party platform so
in a weird way she's gonna lose a little
gay support because gays won't have to
vote at these Democratic gays in the
primaries won't have to vote on gay
issues do you follow me I do she gets
seniority because she's gonna get it
either she's gonna get she gets to earn
it simply because of her history and you
know and I wasn't at the 2005 Pride
Parade it might have been seven at the
time I'm just kidding I wasn't that but
I remember her speech for three minutes
because she
at the UN yeah and that was also very
progressive I believe that was 2010 11
right and and and I was like that's
ballsy because she's speaking to these
countries that we've mentioned earlier
that are very conservative and actually
have laws that persecute gay people and
I so I think gays am i her because
because of the cojones the people people
see story too
yeah like she would be she would be the
first female president and like and I
think like people for better words like
people people that's part of it that's
part of the kind of the enamor and and
that she's just so incredible so this
sort of goes to what we were talking
about with the view but do you guys
think that if there was a gay male that
had the exact same resume I guess that
would be tough because she was first
lady but if there was a gay male who had
the same exact in terms of voting record
and being Pro gay and all that that the
gays would embrace that person I think
the gays using an umbrella well you know
amongst us boys we all know that there's
plenty of segregation discrimination
within the gay community as well
someone's gonna think he's to this
someone think he's gonna nah someone's
gonna want to ask is he a top or a
bottom and they're gonna have an opinion
about that i think i sad to say i don't
know if the gay community would fully
back a gay candidate i think we have to
look at the the gay candidates or the
gay congressman the gay senators that
currently already in office and see what
that kind of voting record has been like
but yeah unfortunately we're just
pickier something about and i don't know
how best to say this but that like not
all gay men enjoy seeing other gay men
succeed what do you love over there that
happens that like where they're very
quick to cut other gay men down yeah so
that's what I was talking about with the
view thing before so what do you think
that's about cuz I do I'd absolutely
think if there was a openly gay
candidate running for president that had
the same exact platform as Hillary the
gays would not be into him and I don't
know what the answer is I think it's
really interesting but on a micro level
you guys are gay YouTube
I mean don't you get plenty of hate from
the gay community oh yeah more heat from
the gay community than from the straight
community yeah yeah it's just and I
don't know go in your own little world
what do you what do you make of that I
think it's it's it's a very complex
question and I think I don't know I
don't know what the easy answer is but I
think what I have seen is that gay men
are very kind of quick to cut each other
down that it's like and I think it's not
something that just happens in the gay
world I think it happens with women
seeing other women succeed I've heard
this from my friends and so I think it's
like a phenomenon that happens in
marginalized communities yeah it's not
it's not a good look but it's definitely
I do I think it's just a projection of
our own insecurities and the things that
we had to deal with and during our
coming-out process and it's and it's
sometimes it's difficult to be happy for
other people when it comes to their
success and I was gonna say if you want
to project the public opinion on a
potential gay presidential candidate you
can just look at some of our gay
celebrities now every public gay
celebrity entertainment usually it can
be a little bit of a lightning rod for
controversy even Anderson Cooper who is
pretty as vanilla as they come people
love them people hate them and we're
talking about just the gays right yeah
yeah well you know you've given me a
perfect segue here because we got one
more segment for you and this is on the
glass closet and I thought it would be
perfect to talk to these guys about this
if you don't know the term the glass
closet it is I'm gonna read this because
I want to get it fully right it is a
term used for a gay person usually a
public figure or celebrity who has never
publicly come out as being gay but is
basically known to be gay there are many
of these people now I'm not gonna out
anyone we had a debate before the show
I'm not going to out anyone here but I
have written four names here on this
piece of paper and I don't want you guys
to repeat these names but there are four
names here that are very very public
people in Hollywood won a major TV star
won a major movie star won a major music
music star etc that pretty much everyone
in the gay community knows is gay again
I am NOT outing anyone I just want you
guys to look at this let's keep it on me
for a second so that the white shot
doesn't even see this
okay now we're just looking at that one
of them's big in news and sort of has
been outed recently by a major newspaper
okay now my question is this yes with
these people I have no reason to think
that any of them are anti-gay actually
some of them have done publicly Pro gay
things but yet they still refuse to just
say it and I'm curious as out people you
guys put a lot of stuff out there you
put your full selves out there you put a
lot of skin out there on top of that
literally you're putting your skin in
the game yeah people have skin into his
game whatever whatever works yeah really
how I cuz I feel very conflicted by
these people I have no doubt that
they're all good people and privately
doing good things I'm probably living
happy lives and all that but as out
people how should we feel about this
group of people that's sort of is
tacitly endorsing this idea that you can
live your life still but don't say it
either one of you take it away I would
say that the coming-out process is
different for everyone and that there's
no right way to do it there's no time
that you need to do it by and and not
that I'm letting any of them off the
hook but that they're probably at
potentially at different points that are
coming out journey and so I think it's
very hard to be critical of people and
and and where they're at and we see the
same thing with with youtubers like that
there's youtubers that are in the closet
and it's easy for us as out youtubers to
say like what are you doing like come
out you can do so much for the cause you
will help change hearts and minds but
they just might not be there yet I mean
there's a lot of processing that has to
happen to get to that point right now
again I don't know either these are
waiting for the book deal so that's I
think maybe woody more because I don't
know any of these people personally but
I'm looking at the four people that I
wrote down here I'm pretty sure these
are all millionaires probably
multimillionaires and isn't that that
tacit endorsement that they're sort of
saying well I could lose this you know
and I could lose my TV show I could lose
my movie etc etc isn't that sort of the
worst message you could be sending to a
fifteen year old that maybe wants to go
in the
these you know you know it mean it wants
to be an actor reason they are isn't the
subliminal message there that this is
almost like the worst thing you could
possibly do I mean if I were to
speculate and I'm not not really in a
position to do so I can only speak from
my own experience but one of them is
also fairly quite young as prominent of
a figure as he is is so I would I think
that it's their own emotional journey
and I have no problem with them choosing
to remain in the closet because they are
so prominent in the public eye as long
as you're not living a life of pot
hypocrisy so as if you're not you know
vocally voting voting against gay rights
or or expressing your disdain then we're
cool and as far as I know most of these
people have also been vocal supporters
of gay rights they've just never joined
the club themselves they've been like
the black oh yeah gays are great love
gays that's not me but love gay rights
oh but that's the weird thing and I
think that's why everyone feels so
conflicted when I showed you guys this
list you both sort of backed up like oh
[ __ ] we better not talk about that list
because there is this unsaid thing right
that we shouldn't really if we were to
say this these names people would go
berserk right I do want to respect
people's privacy I know that coming out
was a difficult process for myself and I
wasn't even online when that happened
this was just my own little world I was
so unbelievably afraid so one can
imagine just what they're going through
so I want to be responsive to that and I
would like to and once they're out I
tell me your story girl let's let's
let's hear it what listen I totally
agree because that's why I did the
segment like this and didn't plaster
their names and everything is the
hypocrisy issue is that the big one for
you if you saw these four names and saw
that one of them was somehow doing some
sort of ad gay thing would that lead you
more I mean that's what leaves the bad
well bad taste in your mouth so so so to
say I think that's we're across the line
and the message that you were saying of
like you know they're millionaires and
they're afraid they're that's probably
not the message that they think that
they're putting out I agree I don't
think they're proactively believing that
they're doing something bad but I do
think especially for one of these people
who's an actor who
it's so hugely successful there is
somehow the implication that my success
is based in me not coming out and I
think that's really dangerous and I know
that doesn't mean I'm gonna out him or
even think I don't even think poorly of
him I don't know him but I think that
that conflicting message is still
something that the gay community is
hasn't quite grappled he thinks the
message that he's putting out is it's
none of your [ __ ] business yeah and
and this is my personal life and it's
and it doesn't matter it shouldn't be
like the message that we're receiving
isn't the same message that he thinks
he's putting out and and it kind of is
what it is yeah I did both are valid
yeah I think his perspective it is it is
valid there are certain things that as
public as I am there's certain things
that I just don't talk about right and
you're not gonna get me to talk about
them because it's none of your goddamn
business will you at least write them on
this paper I'll tell you this I don't
talk about my I don't talk about any
group but any relationships cuz I've
seen you're youtuber celebrities and we
all see you know when you get into very
public romantic entanglements in the
public eye it just the follow it's never
very good I don't know when you started
your blog you did talk about boyfriend's
guys that you were dating yeah it's a
church and state let's keep something
sacred for him his sexual orientation
for some of these people sexual
orientation might be sacred space for
them I don't know I'm now going to crush
this and burn it so I don't tell anyone
you saw that Hank Chen Davey wavey thank
you guys thank you so much you were you
were a little nervous to do something
with a shirt on but I think you pulled
it off yeah I'm definitely outside my
comfort zone with the girls covered up
and I have to say but I can still see
that there yeah very cold yeah very nice
all right well don't forget to like and
comment I'm a youtuber they're youtuber
we know about this like comment
subscribe is there anything else I
should tell them to do follow us all on
Twitter their Twitter's are right down
below anything else anything else post a
picture of us on Instagram well they
should they could do it too and then put
a listen what it let's let's be [ __ ]
about this all your social media Oh
tumblr tumblr